and so I thought the idea within the
case of Pulp Fiction that would be kind
of cool is to take three separate
stories and make them be the oldest
stories in the book you know whether it
be uh Vincent's character or the the
hoodlum has to go out with the bosses
lady but don't touch her and there's a
whole history of people who have touched
her and what happens well we've seen
that before a zillion times in the case
of uh the Bruce Willis story that's
that's the boxer supposed to throw the
fight and he doesn't and now the mob's
after him we've seen that story a
million times before and one of the
things I thought about like the third
story was basically kind of the
beginning of at the at the time of
almost every Joel Silver movie and so I
thought well what happens if we hung out
with them all night long on online all
day long all right after they've killed
the guy what happens to the rest of
their day and so it was the idea of
taking these these chestnuts and putting
them together and then actually having
the characters kind of intertwine and it
all kind of takes place in one one city
and it's an environment that they all
live in and the characters kind of know
each other but you don't know that for a
while and it was just kind of hanging
out with him for those two days